well again coming at this from a from a
left perspective I connect justice with
equality so legal justice means equality
before the law it means that wealth or
family connection or celebrity Fame
doesn't bring you special treatment
which means legal justice is rare in the
in the world but but that's the
conception of legal justice political
justice means one-person one-vote it
means a right of opposition it means
free speech freedom of assembly it means
it means all of those features of of
citizenship that make democratic
politics possible and social justice is
equality of opportunity the openness of
of the of the social system and of the
economic system to ambition and
competence and it means the absence of
such great inequalities as distort legal
justice and political chess